[Music]
in unlikely fine news submitted by
skateboard Dave skateboard P skateboard
Tommy I'm gonna do it but I'm doing it
[ __ ] Oh under a couple's home is likely
an old entry to an eighteen hundred's
gold mine Wow this is a California oh I
want to go panning for gold oh you
didn't find any gold on man it's just
like flying little specks of dust yeah
in Sacramento it was a school field trip
yeah oh yeah it was like pouring rain
and we're out on the river and we're
doing this [ __ ] and I was like man it's
[ __ ] whack as hell you see like
glitters like little sparkles yeah
little flakes yeah but it's like anyone
in your class - no they didn't go to the
right places
the thing is I know those guys know you
ain't gonna find [ __ ] but we're gonna
give you the experience and the hope
since you're a berry farm they have a
cannibal thank you you get out it's
called fool's gold
Oh all right yeah all right I'll watch
gold mining videos on YouTube why like
like instead in modern times they're
like yeah there's there's guys out there
that go out there [ __ ] like do it
there's like machines like you got all
kinds of [ __ ] yeah this is gonna be that
guy with the [ __ ] metal detector at
the beach
I like to watch that guy actually seems
pretty fun down no it doesn't every time
I see a big five ad come out and I see
that I can get one for like 79 bucks I
really want to get a but honestly think
about it like all the people like if you
go to like Santa Monica beach think
about all the people who are there
during the day
somebody's gonna have lost something you
know maybe like a watch or like you know
that's what those guys are I'll do it
should add a rave there we go I always
saw some people losers at night with
like a mask this [ __ ] [ __ ] took this
bike riding right complete tangent took
his bike ridings like yeah we should all
go ride our bikes whatever we go puts it
he puts his headphones in he takes off
and we're like oh [ __ ] oh yeah I guess
we start now and then we're like trying
to chase down chase them down almost
never caught up to him you're like you
guys go into it thinking it's gonna be a
leisurely yeah like Dave's all he got is
tight pants [ __ ] even the helmet with
well because I'm used to biking with
Muriel and Muriel leaves me behind so I
assume that I'm slow yeah yeah yeah
so much you already in that mentality if
I gotta go my mentor my mentality I'm
the slow one yeah so I was like hold on
a second because they're like you cuz
who came up to be bar caught up to me
with Tyga yeah lawyer telling you a
[ __ ] I'm tired let's slow down you
did it anyway after we stopped and you
went again alright yeah but what we
stopped there was that [ __ ] dope ass
[ __ ] downhill and that [ __ ] was funny
anyway I need to get a bike
me too I don't know
how snacking where bikes he got him at
uh REI I like REI Ashley from what about
Ashley thank you from North Carolina she
she heard some noise actually she was
digging out Christmas decorations and
from her basement and then that's when
all of a sudden this hole appeared and
it engulfed one of the pillars holding
up her home she was digging out [ __ ]
Christmas ornament ornaments why today
do you got that mommy bring back again
dear me being pregnant no she was
digging for some [ __ ] [ __ ] larvae
instant the way they worded this is
digging out Christmas ornaments why is
she why are the Christmas ornaments in
the ground yeah like she preserves it in
the look we needed backstory to that in
February that's even weirder like okay
maybe she stores her ornaments with her
kimchi that's like some [ __ ] like we
[Laughter]
talked to you said that is highly likely
what it is the excitement [ __ ]
basement and we are now trying to
struggle with okay like what do we do
the couple had to make a temporary fix a
beep supporting the home instead okay
first the whale where is so confused
this is Carolina North Carroll okay this
first of all is in a basement who the
[ __ ] plants a Christmas tree in their
basement right well when you move in
don't you look at all the home space you
know you check out your basement you
didn't see this big-ass gaping hole no
and it seems like gaping ass at all No
if they catch it no one holds on to
we're trying to move on in the [ __ ]
story why is it but you're just I don't
know what or Vernon sorry I don't know
who this gaping how is all this story
right now it's too hard the second video
I'm not going to talk to if I come to
your house on Christmas and you put
orbitons I'll be so upset yeah but he's
holding on to it like it's that crazy I
know you think I'm perfect
but here you go you gaping hole dude so
then apparently now it just swallowed up
her entire pillar so they put up its
most likely an entrance into old does it
even matter the gold mine probably shut
down like a long time ago so it's not
easy for a reason there's no goal isn't
even mattering - would not think oh yeah
really it's a goal it's like [ __ ]
someone was murdered in this hole yeah
exactly what you guys call Explorer if
you guys would wish that there's extra
gold that they didn't get I'm with the
[ __ ] side of the table a little
claustrophobic though can't do that yes
because I would probably try to build
like beams as I'm going so that it
wouldn't collapse the further I get you
lost me at build get like little 3/4
last time you build something on my
workbench well we are we gonna build on
it any nothing I just needed it cuz I
have a house now it's like I can need to
do this because I have out yeah in
Croatia we went into this replica of a
coal mine and it's really cramped like
you can't even like you can't fence
I liked it if I was hugging you yeah I
was nice but yeah you just you feel like
you can't breathe in there and it was a
replica it wasn't even the real thing
like my question is why is that even
news is why if I saw that I'd say who
gives a [ __ ] maybe they live in a really
peaceful part of like that City County
yeah cuz I know I had a friend Charlotte
Charlotte oh yeah she has a really
pretty view of the entire city so she's
saying this is like her dream home cuz
she's always wanted a home that has like
it's either in the city or has a view of
the city and so now they're really
bummed out cuz they're like the only
permanent solutions that they have found
out about it's too expensive for them so
they're like we're probably gonna have
to end up moving out he's gonna collapse
yeah yeah she says I'm tense you're a
walk through the oh because that pillar
that was holding the home it's it's like
really important to the structure
because it holds I feel like that's a
lawsuit though like that's a lawsuit
whoever sold the property to them unless
they're dumbasses built on top oh yeah
no one probably knew but also in LA like
we're used to hearing so many horror
stories of homes and [ __ ] that it just
might be different like in other places
like just like the quality of everything
is just better so when they get
something like this it's like oh I
wasn't expecting it cuz I hear it's like
oh you got mold tell me what else what's
new
what there were ten people buried under
your house that said we had 12 there was
an underground tunnel that went all the
way to Tijuana from your house oh yeah
those the same things yours it's termite
issues right the [ __ ] black mold and
then the earthquake [ __ ] is not up to
date initiatives all the house didn't
Issac find a cat skeleton yeah it was
right under our home that's not hard
cats do that [ __ ] that is scary that's
not scary that's really cool
a witch's pet that's petrified that
means a witch used to live there you'd
be the scared would not surprise that
she's nice I just I grew up with cats so
I know cat behavior and especially when
cats like that that's just their shells
don't even give a [ __ ] when they died in
[Laughter]
time there I'm out I'm like yeah that's
so crazy good thing I heard that they
they want to get away from their owner
yes yeah they're embarrassed of their
death yeah they just like go off until
they're like I don't know they're just
like be with me when I die they leave
two dogs go into hiding no really good
after my dog dies I'm not getting in
that dog hey you don't even have your
dog I am gonna bring it back when I live
in a place where I could have a dog your
parents are so attached to it or married
oh I'm taking my floor is it your
brother now what does it matter if
they're attached to her they're not
she's not attached to them when I'm when
I'm around my parents don't even exist
cuz I guess that dog whatever pressures
on me or some [ __ ] yeah so like whenever
I'm around like oh she remembers
everybody sent me to some show
especially when she was super young if
she saw you frequently she remembers me
my brother Mariel definitely you cuz you
saw her more than Marilyn
yeah I think people like really
underestimate like what it's like when
when you lose a pet like a dog or a cat
oh no you don't tell me I lost a phone
my grandma just died shut up [ __ ]
tears that woman my grandma [ __ ]
thanks so much I love brown
I love her too but she's not dead okay I
love her too but she's not dead it's
like it's like artists okay like they
get better when you die you know what I
mean they're worth more when you dies
but you can have them anymore yeah you
just have the memories
[Music]